and we're back
did you guys see how Bubba Wallace
fumbled his 34:30
this guy had the perfect the perfect
storyline setup for an amazing 30 for 30
okay okay yeah all he had to do was
drive around in a circle faster than
other people right I'm Bubba Wallace is
the black NASCAR driver he originally
comes out with black lives matter he get
he gets the Confederate flag taken down
from all NASCAR events then a noose ends
up in his they call it garage but just
to clarify garages each team gets their
own section of the thing and they call
that a garage so it's not the garage in
his hometown it's at the venue right so
which I think was set up but we'll get
there in a second and then he goes out
there and the entire NASCAR the stamms
that all the other drivers everybody
roll his car up to the front of the
lineup and they show this huge sign of
solidarity
he's crying it's just this beautiful
moment and then he comes in 14th if he
wins that race oh my god is amazing it's
30 for 30 if he wins that race yeah 30
for [ __ ] 30 done amazing story
[ __ ] 30 for 30 you gotta have cinema
movies you might get a real movie play
by Shaun King yeah Shaun King what game
being the guy that hangs the news so so
here's the question um I mean it's just
this perfect story and like I don't I
think the noose was set up I mean no way
to prove it or there's no way to prove
it here I think we'd do it I think
somebody who is either on his team I
don't think the person who did it did it
for like intimidation purposes I think
the person who did go go good okay I
think the person who did it did it for
PR purposes
I could say I could oh you saying NASCAR
would do this to say yo the stereotype
of our fan base of our drivers is
they're all racist [ __ ] so let's do
some real foul shitless set it up but
then the reaction to it will be so
open-minded and accepting of this black
driver people will see yo not all of our
fans are like that not all of our
drivers are like that so if you're a
reason for shutting out NASCAR's it's
some white racist [ __ ] yo maybe you'll
be a little bit more open to him be like
oh they're not they're not all bad yep
which is ironic they're having to fight
for that and what and what was the
picture that we saw all these everybody
on screaming the top of their lungs
black lives matter on the green
she gave me chills just then when he
said it bro it was beautiful some moment
brah and then he [ __ ] it up coming in
14th place don't you just crash the car
just go for number one foot on the pedal
whole [ __ ] time I may just pretend
you know they should have done to
motivate him somebody should have put a
siren on their hood behind fighting for
your life yeah but they should have
treated it like Kobe's last game just
let him win let him win like out-lap
everybody by like four laps just like
kill it that's what they shouldn't be
honest I'm so competitive I don't even
let my girl win so I don't know but uh
but I hear you man like just I don't
know dawg these people are so
competitive but don't you wish she
[ __ ] won that would have been the
perfect idea what the newts I'm gonna
defy the news I'm gonna go out there I
win all of the NASCAR fans are out there
in support everybody's cheering all the
other drivers are cheering he's shaking
the champagne he's pouring it all over
the [ __ ] place brah
you think you just got too emotional
early on you can't cry before some [ __ ]
and then expect to go out there and kill
it but it's driving why are we acting
like this is difficult probably why they
do that probably why they put the noose
in his thing like to wrap up it just
didn't work and then everybody [ __ ] it
up by by accepting him he's like goddamn
yeah
yeah I think they put it there for
motivational artists I'm the liar under
him right before the race like that's
better choice of words like fire bro
this is interesting what if it wasn't a
noose at all what if it was like a
bungee cord or some [ __ ] like what if
who's just something for the car and
then someone just forgot to like pass he
showed up the next day and then all the
people on his team like to come so early
on race day I'm gonna put there I'm not
gonna say anything like it is yo it's to
the point right now if you're white you
can't even buy rope be brah like who we
really remember that time we're white
people did that tiki torch it and you
couldn't have a [ __ ] Hawaiian
barbecue in the back of your house
without barbecue barbecue call them
[Laughter]
nobody cares
[Music]
I hate him what scared to say so but
yeah isn't that so what were we even
talking about oh he knows oh yeah so
that was the Bubba Wallace thing that
thing would have been perfect right it
would've been the perfect [ __ ] story
how do you not risk it all like even if
you go down like getting you know pulled
out you got a go for it right oh if he
crashed and that's the greatest 34:30 if
you crash yeah I ever think about that
thirty four thirty I should have liked
Ford versus Ferrari both higher stakes
hmm so but what would it mean what do
you think it would mean like if he died
do you think the message would be
prolonged did you think someone would
look like they bumped him off the track
on purpose I tell you what some of these
white women wouldn't been getting the
same amount of attention you know that's
a stretch for me BLM cause that's a
[ __ ] great point
wait a minute how on earth was he not
trying to cut everyone off you don't
want to be the person that could one day
the black lives matter race yeah that's
why I think they put the noose in so he
drive more aggressive and they should
have let him win we gotta have a talk
with Bubba son you need to win that one
[Applause]